when I kill your enjoyment it's been a
while since I've done a nitpick ranted
this one is a little bit different than
some of the others because this one I
actually feel is a bit more substantive
than I usually get into I still think it
qualifies as a nitpick though because it
is one specific scene and it's one
specific element of an otherwise
gloriously great movie so the movie I'm
talking about is Who Framed Roger Rabbit
what a wonderful movie this is it is so
unique for so many reasons on so many
levels but it's got one scene and one
thing about it that really I don't want
to say traumatize me but shook me as a
kid and it still does as an adult to the
point that I actually tend to skip this
scene when I'm watching it and because
of this scene alone I don't know how old
I want my kid to be by the time I let
her watch this
and I know some people have brought up
you know traumatic elements of this and
a lot of people cite judge doom he does
factor into this but it's probably not
the thing you're thinking oh I think a
lot of people think of judge doom they
think you know when his eyes go all King
and the boys go screeching and he's kind
of psychotic and no I was fine with that
didn't really bug me as a kid didn't
really traumatize me or if it did it
didn't stick because it all turns out
okay and he's defeated in the end and
sort of I as a kid I always roll with
scary stuff as long as it was fine by
the end but there's there's an element
in this film involving judge doom that
isn't fine that's actually really messed
up so I need to talk about that shoe the
shoe that gets dipped to demonstrate
that tooms can be killed I've got a
couple of really big problems with this
first of all it's kind of horrifying I
mean it is it is legitimately tragically
brutally gratuitously this
yes you don't watch the thing melt but
you you see it hit the dip and whimper
and cry and you can hear it dying and
any pull I found it's just all this
melted paint and ink and it it's
horrifying but that horrifying this
alone is not the reason I need to talk
about this and I need to kind of really
pick up this thing it's because there's
no justice for that shoe and I'm not
joking I am dead serious this bothers
the hell out of me there isn't even
proper acknowledgement of what it is
that just happened because that shoe
committed no crime yes what the judge
obviously he wants to just be able to
dip any tune he wants fine he has a
justification for going after Roger
Roger is suspected a murder all that
shoe did was nuzzle up against him and
in front of a room of cups he dips this
thing and kills it and yes I do
understand that there's a certain
analogy towards your racism and other
prejudices and the police aren't looking
out for toons
I do get that but the degree to which
this pushes it speaking as someone who
was a child when I watch this with
authority figures all around including
the hero of the story who just let this
happen and the only acknowledgment is
that everyone's kind of just a little
grossed out little is that's the worst
reaction including from the hero of the
story that's the worst reaction you get
from any out of this there's no proper
knowledge 'men of how horrible this
thing was that he just did and before
anyone tries to make the argument to me
well of oh well that's the point because
it shows what second-class citizens
toons are there are plenty of other
things in this movie that already do
that I'm going to remind you the age
group that this is aimed at to do it in
this fashion is
really gratuitous and brutal and brutal
and pointless but I still might have
been okay with it if there had been
justice for that shoe and I think
there's a we you don't have to even have
to change hardly anything about the
movie I'm gonna tell you exactly how you
could have done it would have been so
easy so here's something nobody ever
thinks about shoes come in pairs there
is now a widowed shoe that was the other
half of that pair now first of all
that's never acknowledged either and if
you were trying to emphasize through
this needless brutality yeah what
second-rate citizens twos are and what a
horrible thing this is I would think
point out the fact that there's now a
widowed shoe would have been a good
thing to emphasize and would have shown
that this thing mattered more than a
plot point to just haven't died to
establish how the tip works so first of
all you acknowledge that there is now a
widow chew there is another half there
was an incomplete pair you show it maybe
not net and show it watching this happen
I think that might be too much but like
towards the end of the scene see that
it's often a corner sort of looking
around a box tear down the eye and that
and then it sneaks off in the warehouse
now that is the same warehouse that the
final showdown happens between doom and
Eddie so what happens at the end of this
movie how does any defeat doom he
defeats doom by grabbing this mallet
thing that has a punch glove that comes
out and it hits the nozzle and the depth
comes out and that's the end of judge
doom
now that mallet does get properly
established as these things do actually
in that same scene where the dipping
occurs but it's just a mallet it's just
a prop it has no particular significance
imagine how much more cathartic it would
have been when Eddie was reaching around
for something to fight back with instead
of finding that mallet his hand lands on
the other shoe and that shoe established
it a little bit earlier in the scene
that it's in the warehouse and that it's
watching what's going on have that shoe
get into Eddie's hand voluntarily
have Eddie throw that
you have that be the thing that sets off
the dip have that shoe have its moment
of justice have redemption for Eddie
because he didn't stop that thing
that happened before but now he can try
and do this little thing to make it
right justice for the shoe for crying
out loud we had a whole hashtag in a
movement with stranger things for
justice for barb
justice for the shoe hashtag justice for
cartoon show so that's something in an
otherwise really great movie that really
really really bothers me kind of a
deeper level than these nitpicks usually
do but yeah it is at the end of the day
just one scene and otherwise brilliant
movie so of that it's gonna do it for
this particular nitpick rant what are
your thoughts on this that I just I just
ruin another movie for you
I've been accused of that a few times
with this already but in any case let me
know what your thoughts are drop them
down in the comments and don't forget to
Like subscribe check me out on Twitter
at Council of geeks give a list in the
counsel of geeks podcasts it's on Apple
podcasts and stitcher radio I'm one half
of the punch like a girl podcast that is
a presentation of the fire and water
podcast network fire and water park has
calm I know I'm talking really fast but
there's links for all this stuff below
if you really want it and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]